there's mike voltanevich on the mound
for the rangers there's how he's fared
in 20 starts this season second half
hasn't quite been kind to him yet this
one lined out to center white
cuts over quickly to his left to make
the play
and there's that breaking ball again
strike three called
and henniger goes down looking two away
good to see faulty get off to a good
start 2-2
and this one lined out to left field
dahl to his left and he makes the catch
it's a one two three for mike fulton
that's the way to start it this
afternoon and marco gonzalez get the
start this will be his 14th start on the
year three and five record at five four
eight era and 67 and a third he has 56
strikeouts over 26 walks
right back there again punched it and
coming on nicely done by jake bowers
first baseman by trade a good fast
runner and he got a good break on that
one opponent's hitting 250 off of his
change up and he goes back to back chain
jumps both of them just off the outside
corner and
yeah how about some defensive help nice
play eye powers in right field again
haniger the dh
breaking ball jpf taking himself
and now the first thing is complete they
got bases loaded nobody out here for cal
raleigh one strike pitch and this one
high in the air out to right field
garcia in position he makes the catch
tagging at third france and they'll hold
him and that's a good reason why
a one-off strike to the plate as this
rangers outfield defense continues to
dazzle the one out for jake bowers this
is still loaded
base hit and a nice scoop there by
garcia
everybody will move up 90 feet
one-nothing mariners
jake bowers jumping on the first pitch
his eighth rbi since coming over to the
mariner ball club get it on the butt
yeah maybe a little bit of luck involved
here's a change up middle of the plate
and he squares it up solid line drive
garcia thought he had a chance to make
the catch and
kind of off to the side
able to pick it
in between hop and that was hit on the
button 109 on the exit velocity there's
dylan moore with the bases loaded 3-2
pitch
ball four works as well to another
faces loaded walk this week for dylan
moore two-nothing mariners tap the order
j.p crawford and this one lined to
second base and there's your double play
all right
so hit a rocket to short
and it results in two outs rangers don't
care they'll take it here comes the
bottom of the second here comes andy
abundas to lead off against marco
gonzalez
shoots a liner up the middle that's a
base hit
all right so
second rangers hit and here's the pitch
and that one is lying softly into right
field a base hit beyond the reach of
toro
so reaching for an outside change up and
just poking it the opposite way
the rangers continuing to have some
success
not pulling the ball against gonzales
none of their three hits have been
pulled
ibanez is now at third base and white on
the fielder's choice is it first and
david dahl will be the batter going
lefty against lefty there's a bouncer
down to first base they're gonna go for
the double play and they will not get it
the rangers score a run on the play
that's interesting
france had come in for the baseball did
not bother looking at banyas back to
third
two outs here's garcia
the 2-1 pitch swinging this is line
right to jp crawford leaping catch
climbing the ladder and snare it in the
webbing of his glove that is a fantastic
play by jp taking a hit away from
adolesce garcia here we go to the fifth
inning it's 2-1 seattle dylan moore to
lead it off there's a swing and there's
a pop-up into short right field garcia
coming on and he makes a shoestring
catch
barely avoiding a collision with andy
avanyas nice play by adobe staying up on
his feet
there's a swing in a line drive to right
garcia loses the ball in the lights and
drops to his knees and makes the catch
well he threw his glove up in front of
his face maybe just self-defense there
but he made the play as he lost that
ball at the last instant
another wicked line drive out off the
bat of jp crawford
there's a swing in a slow ground ball
wide a third it is cut off on a bare
hand by culvers and he whips it to first
for the out
pretty play by charlie culverson
bare-handed to throw out mitch haniger
it's a one-two-three inning for fulton
middle of the fifth two one seattle
anager will face cotton 1-2 pitch
flip shot that may work it will jp
is on the move digging for third he'll
get the stop sign from maddie and the
mariners have runners at the corners
with two outs here in the seventh now
the mariners in business now with two
outs for kyle seeger delivered
that is going to work kyle seeger
a bunt rbi and the mariners have a 3-1
lead here in the seventh they gave it to
him he took it
surprised everybody in the ballpark
including this ballpark
well they had the shift on and he just
had to try to get it past the pitcher
cotton goes over with the backhand to
play but there's not a play at first
there's nobody over there culverson is
playing over towards the shortstop
position the heads-up play by the
veteran that was outstanding one away
for the mariners top of the eighth
that'll bring up center fielder jared
kellner the other way that's gonna work
a base hit pitch you away take it the
other way a lot of hits live out that
way good count for cal tunnel
he delivers base hit right field
stopping at second is kelnig haters
count it paid off one out two on is up
jake bowers
up the middle out of the reach of kinder
philippa
coming around and stumbling now
scrambling back to third
is kelnick they picked up the stop sign
from maniac really late
fortunately he was able to get back
there's dylan moore base is loaded oh
big strikeout for demarcus evans as he
ran that one past dylan moore two away
now there's that fastball and so much of
the time
in this world that we live in
with that four seamer we hear that
fastball plays up
base is loaded full count the payoff and
he swings and misses
and evans gets out of the bases loaded
jam of the eighth inning
ninth inning eric swanson is on in the
ninth fourth seattle this one up the
middle that's a base hit
rangers have the lead man on in the
ninth
now the tying run is at the plate
and this ball hit well deep out to left
that one is gone
and
tied the game
third home run of the year for andy
abagnes and he knocks it up in the ninth
inning big time heroics and consecutive
nights for the rangers gets a slider in
the middle of the play to his liking and
hits a bullet
out to left field
right man in the right spot
and he's pumped about it so nobody on
base for jonah but he can still provide
the winner that ball hit well deep out
to right has he done it again
gone
jonah
and the rangers win it again and they're
finally
unbelievable
two nights in a row for jonah hein these
guys are fun again